ein weiterer ganz großer streitpunkt bei
den verhandlungen war in den letzten
tagen das thema gesundheit genauer
gesagt unsere zwei klassen medizin in
deutschland hält als letztes land in
europa am dualen system aus gesetzlicher
und privater krankenkassen fest 61
prozent der deutschen also eine mehrheit
wünschen sich eine bürgerversicherung
dazu muss man wissen das gefühl von
ungleichbehandlung ist tatsächlich gift
für eine gesellschaft hier zwei ard
kollegen versuchen mal einen termin zu
kriegen er versucht bei einem hautarzt
in neu isenburg für mich gilt hier ende
april
mein kollege als privatpatient hat bei
ihm mehr glück das ist mir
wahrscheinlich etwas zu kurzfristig
heute gleich siehste jetzt muss der
private sich voll beeilen das so
ungerecht ja kein wunder dass da bei den
kassenpatienten in deutschland über die
jahre schon ein gefühl der
minderwertigkeit entstanden ist muss man
ganz klar sagen und dass das geht jetzt
gar nicht gegen die ärzte das geht jetzt
ausdrücklich nicht gegen die ärzte dass
systeme schuld wir müssen wissen für
einen privaten patienten bekommen die
ärzte im schnitt so viel geld wie für
drei gesetzliche für die gleiche
behandlung wohlgemerkt das heißt am
quartalsende kann sich der arzt die
behandlung von kassen vier eigentlich
gar nicht mehr leisten
es rechnet sich einfach nicht das ist
tatsache
und sowas wirkt sich natürlich auch auf
die behandlungszeiten aus man hat
einfach für kassenpatienten wenig zeit
ja innerhalb von fünf minuten sind sie
manchmal auch kurz angebunden und machen
flüchtigkeitsfehler ist doch klar das
ist doch klar menschlich kleiner fun
fact am rande
mehr als die hälfte der privat
versicherten sind beamte
das heißt die kriegen für ihre beiträge
bei hilfen aus steuergeld es dürfte sich
also gar nicht privat nennen im grund
ist dass kommunismus
ja wir bräuchten ein gerechteres
honorarsystem für ärzte aber die
üblichen lobbyverbände trommeln gerade
wie wild damit sich hier bloß nichts
ändert hier ein süßer original
propagandafilm pkv und gkv kümmern sich
um die bezahlbarkeit von leistungen
einfach klasse aber einige politische
parteien wollen eine einheitskasse
einführen
die sogenannte bürgerversicherung die
erfolgreiche zusammenarbeit von
gesetzlicher und privater
krankenversicherung soll abgeschafft
werden
eine initiative der betriebsräte der
krankenversicherer gkv und pkv werden
getrennt voll fies haben sich so gut
verstanden die beiden hier kurz zur
realität
das ist gkv der hat einen schlimmen
herzfehler unten ab ist ein
aber er kommt beim arzt trotzdem nicht
dran denn er ist nur gkv was für ein
idiot
das ist pkv pkv hat blähungen und ihm
ist langweilig er kommt sofort dran gkv
und pkv was für ein tolles team
dieser sei